Yes, I'm Risa.
[Music]
Yes, I was
really influenced by Acrylic Lavigne when I was a student,
so I always create music with that kind of music and sound in
mind.
Well, my original experience with that music
was Avril Lavigne and Drink, and I
feel like these punk rock heroes and heroines, who became legends, have come back to life and are now regaining their momentum.  Yes, that's because the
very young generation has made punk and
rock so
popular, so I
feel like the things I like are becoming popular again, so I
'm really happy.
[Music]
Yes, I've been involved in a lot of anime works.
By doing this,
when I go to perform not only in Japan but also all over the world, I see the
local people singing along with me in Japanese, and through my
work I am able to connect with people from many different countries.
[Music] I would like to say that through the
theme song that I was involved in for the anime work, I was able to get to know the core of my musicality, and I was able to learn about the
music that comes
with it.  Niko: I always
include my own songs, which have a similar or rather similar musicality, in the setlist with the hope that people will enjoy them as well.I
want people to listen to this one in particular.
Before I discovered Kimetsu no Yaiba, I had the impression that a lot of my songs were
quite difficult, or hard songs,
but when I
discovered Demon Slayer: Kimetsu no Yaiba,
songs like Gurenge and Fire came out.  I
feel like it has a very ballad feel to it, so I
hope people will enjoy ballads
as there are a lot of good ballads.  I'm
very proud of the song Graing, which has become so popular because I was producing it, and I
feel very happy.
[Music]
I
was in a band before I debuted as Lisa.  At that time, when you think about what you
can do to make the people at the back have fun when the floor is not yet warm, if you
raise your hand higher than your heart even just once.
When I heard a rumor that people were getting excited, I wondered what would be good about it, and I thought that if PS was something we all did together, it would be
really easy to create a sense of unity, so I
started it, feeling like I was lighting a fire.  Let's
enjoy it to the fullest
with the word "peace" and from there, from there, and from there, and
when we imagine everyone going out from the live house and having fun, today is also a good day,
because by wrapping up like this, we'll do our best tomorrow as well.  I
conclude with these words, hoping that people will enjoy it.Well,
I'm
sure everyone has heard my song as the theme song for an anime,
so
when I sing that song live, I'll use it as the theme song.  The first
verse of the song is already being sung in chorus in Japanese,
but when the second verse hits, it's
amazing.It really shows how much people are
enjoying my songs along with the anime.
[Music] I
feel that anime works are the ones that make me feel very proud of Japanese culture, or rather Japanese works.It's also the story.  That
's right, and the same goes for the music that accompanies the story, and I'm
very conscious that it's a piece of work that I'm sending out as a Japanese person.
In particular, I
was conscious of the melody and sound that Japanese people find very easy to get into, so I guess I'll have a
little bit of AB instead.Western
music is very big, but I wanted to create a
melody that would be easy to get used to in various worlds.  I was very
conscious
of this when I produced it, and I wanted to create a sense of scale between the mixed sounds, so I
asked Zack to mix it.
[Music]
That's a really difficult question.  I'm looking
forward to it.
[Music]
Yes, you really said that.
As you said,
releasing a CD is something that takes a lot of time and
a lot of thought
put into it, so the way
you put your thoughts into it is really true.  I
call it a love letter because I think it's a love letter that conveys love and affection.
[Music]
When I went to Taiwan to prevent a concert, the
weather wasn't great, so I was
heading to the airport by plane, but there was a
typhoon.  I couldn't get off the plane, so I couldn't land.
But I heard that Taiwanese fans were waiting for me at the airport I was supposed to get off at,
so what should I do?
Go to another airport over there.  I
thought that everyone would be sad if it all went away, but when the
people who were at that airport during that big journey waited for me at the other airport for about an hour and a half, I was
so happy when I was greeted like this.  I was surprised by
Panda Express.
Panda Express is also available in Japan today,
but
that's exactly what you get when you go to Los Angeles or other
American-style overseas destinations, and you can eat it at the airport.  So
when I want to eat something like that, I
always look for Panda Express, which recently opened in Japan.
[Music] I
want fried rice and rice, so I
always
order rice.
[Music]
5 Centimeters Per Second  Mr. Shinkai has
already done a lot of big works, such as ``What's Your Name?'',
but when I saw this quiet piece called 5 Centimeters per Second, I was struck by
how beautiful the painting was, and the
simple effect.  The story is made up of these elements,
but the story is also very beautiful, and I was very moved by the fact that today's
animation is like this.The
timing was 12 years ago when I became involved in an animation work.
There's a guy named Jun Maeda who produced the music for that work, and he recommended it to me, saying that if you're involved in an anime project,
you should definitely see this.
[Music]
But one of the characteristics of Japanese animation is that the
pictures are beautiful, which is an essential feature.The
pictures in movies like Violet Evergarden are beautiful, so I
hope people enjoy them.
[Music]
Yes,
it's a song from the Spider-Verse movie, niered by Metro Moomy. I was
really excited when I made it because I was thinking about what would happen if my song was lined up here when I was planning on doing Spider-Verse.
While I'm listening to the Spider Bass playlist, I'm adding things like "washing my hands" to it.
[Music] The
Minions
first started with Despicable Me,
and when they met Despicable Me, they said something like, ``That's it.''
When the yellow character first appeared in a trailer at the movie theater, I was
captivated by its shape and have
loved Minions ever since.Minions There are
so many Minions in my house.Just like in
that Minions movie, there are
all kinds of Minions.  I have a lot of figurines in my house.
Strawberry donuts
[Music] When I
say strawberry donuts, they're
not jam-like donuts, they're a bit
like this. They're mixed with white chocolate, and the
strawberries are
stepping on the tip.My
songs are pretty fast and expensive.  Because of
this, I tend to push myself upwards, and my
weight rises to the top, so I
try to keep things in order because I want to be solid.I've never been to New York,
so I've never been to
New York.  I see a lot of different scenes there
, but I've never been there before, so I'd like to go and have a
live performance there.No, it's
not there right now, but I've
been to Mexico once before, so I really want to go there.  I
said I was worried that there would be someone in such a far away place to take care of me, but everyone welcomed me with such great enthusiasm that it melted away my worries, so I
want to go again.
[Music]
I've been drinking tea at home forever.
Yes, especially, but I guess Earl Gray is the best. I'm a
shut-in.
[Music]
I'm happy to stay at home all the time. Especially in Tokyo,
people are really hot these days.  There's so much outside and it's so hot,
so I'm going to stay indoors and cool
off in a cool room.Well, when I lived in my hometown in Gifu, I really liked going out a lot,
but since I came to Tokyo, I've been
staying indoors a lot.
I'm going to shut myself up and watch about 5 movies in a row.
[Music]
Yes, headphones. I
really like listening to loud music through speakers,
but I really like headphones because it allows me to enjoy music that only I like in my own world.  I
also like headphones as a fashion item.
[Music] It's a
completely sweet thing. I
especially love red
bean paste. [Music] I really like Japanese sweets. If I had to choose between
cake or anmitsu, I would
choose anmitsu. Yes
[Music] Is
this the way you do it?  It
's action for both the viewer and the viewer.
Yes, I want it to be refreshing.
When I watch a work, I want to cut it,
so it's action.
[Music]
Marvel always gives me a refreshing feeling.
Also, Fast & Furious
[Music]  ]
But the result is a
hero.
[Music]
Even among Disney movies, I
really like villain movies. But
overall, the result is a hero. Thank you very much.
[Music]